il
à moyens
les enjeux
venise février 1996 le théâtre de la
fenice brûle la violence de l'incendié
menace la ville les pompiers se battront
toute la nuit au matin le feu est éteint
du théâtre il ne reste que les murs mais
la ville est sauvé les 250 pompiers ne
venise ont rempli leur mission ils sont
les gardiens de la ville musée où chaque
intervention est particulière le cas de
l'opéra de la fenice est exceptionnel ce
théâtre était en rénovation
quand nous avons été alertés il était
déjà trop tard
nous avons limité les dégâts en balisant
certaines parties du théâtre nous avons
essayé d'empêcher le feu de se propager
vers le reste de la vie
[Musique]
ensuite nous avons essayé de limiter les
dégâts à l'intérieur du théâtre
nous avons réussi à maîtriser la
situation malgré le vent du soir qui
portaient les braises vers le reste de
la ville ici à venise les vigiles du
cheveu sont une institution hautement
reconnus les gens nous aiment beaucoup
car nous nous occupons tous les
problèmes de la ville nous portons
secours aux personnes âgées malades
nous sauvons des vies humaines c'est
pourquoi nous avons la reconnaissance
entière de tous les habitants de cette
ville
[Musique]
fava
pour les 75000 habitants de venise les
pompiers sont un peu les baby-sitters de
la ville on les appelle pour tous les
problèmes bon il va falloir aller
chercher les chaînes italiennes qu'est
ce qui s'est passé là quel est le
problème
on doit faire venir l'échelle pour aller
chercher le petit chat là haut
madame s'il vous plaît laissez nous
travailler
allez bonne journée à tous
et il adore
m
ils sont prêts copine
ouais
oui
[Applaudissements]
venise est la seule ville au monde où ne
circule aucun véhicule
les pompiers doivent s'entraîner
quotidiennement leur forme physique est
essentielle pour chaque intervention
il porte tout leur équipement sur le dos
y compris les échelles c'est le système
de l'échelle italienne l'échelle
italienne est une exclusivité en italie
quand on assemble cette échelle on
arrive à 10 mètres 33 venise on utilise
seulement les chaînes italiennes et les
chaînes accrochées peut pas utiliser
autre chose
les moyens en place ne le permettent pas
il n'y a pas de route
on ne peut pas amener la grande échelle
avec le camion lorsque l' échelle ne
peut pas être utilisé ils ont recours à
une technique périlleuse et insolite le
trampoline
[Musique]
ouais
c'est un malaise la porte est fermée de
l'intérieur
on va devoir prendre les chaînes
italiennes il n'y a que deux casernes de
pompiers pour toute la ville par
roulement de 25 hommes il veille à tour
de rôle 24 heures d'affilée
cantareil et genève
[Applaudissements]
c'est là haut c'est bon c'est ouvert si
la personne a eu un malaise chez elle et
les gens n'ont pas voulu l'emmener à
l'hôpital ni même à appeler leur médecin
en fait elle doit être hospitalisé
comme les pompiers les ambulanciers
recul sur les canaux
quel étage c'est en premier
[Musique]
appelés pour un incendie les pompiers
sont confrontés à des problèmes de
venise les marais à marée basse les
canaux deviennent impraticables
c'est la marée basse
bâti au 6e siècle essentiellement sur du
bois
venise est une ville à haut risque le
moindre incendie même celui d'une
poubelle peut tourner au désastre
[Musique]
paula rego
c'est qu'on connaît
c'est important de chanter les
traditions ne doivent pas se faire en
chantant ses chansons parce qu'elle nous
motive
et puis parce qu'on se sent tous
vénitien ses chansons appartient à venir
c'est comme les napolitains qui chante
des chansons napolitaines
nous nous sommes de vrais vénitien pas
des campagnards comme celui là à venise
nous vivons sur la mer il nous avons un
mode de vie complètement différents de
ceux qui habitent sur la terre ferme
aussi bien au niveau de la mentalité des
comportements que des traditions
c'est à vivre l'église
eux mêmes
lozeau les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fausse alerte
les grandes interventions ici à venir ça
n'arrive pas souvent on a surtout des
petites interventions des petits
incidents des embarcations qui se
perdent ou qui s'échouent enfin ce genre
de choses ça fait partie de venise mise
à part la fenice
le printemps est là
venise est un labyrinthe
même les pompiers s'ils perdent c'est la
seule ville à avoir instauré le sens
interdit pour piétons
ici ce n 4 bronze le 12 le 26 veni
s'enfonce dans les sables de 25 cm tous
les cent ans
depuis quatorze siècles ce propriétaire
en fait les frais ça porte à bouger il
ne veux plus rentrer chez lui c'est la
grosse clé c'est un look est comme dans
l'ancien temps
attention il ya un chat dangereux à
l'intérieur vous voulez la chance est
avec vous ce que je peux vous offrir
quelque chose
venez tous manger à la maison que
puis-je faire de plus messieurs merci
beaucoup
money c'est comme ça toutes les
interventions que l'on fait et qui n'ont
pas de sens
comme la femme qui a du plâtre qui
s'effrite et qui veut que les pompiers
viennent réparer comme ça c'est gratuit
ça attire la foule ou alors c'est un
problème d'antenne ce genre
d'intervention de routine ne nous motive
pas en revanche quand il s'agit de
sauver des gens c'est ce qui compte le
plus pour nous même si on ne le fait
qu'une fois par an ou tous les dix ans
c'est ça qui nous motive
on est
[Musique]
et
voilà
bien sûr
[Musique]
attendez la hat attendait un peu là
et alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
qu'est ce que vous faites là alors comme
ça entendre de l'escalier bon c'est une
personne âgée elle est tombée d'un
escalier
nous l'avons trouvée par terre
c'est un jeune homme qui a une vue sur
cet escalier qui nous a alertés ça fait
un jour et demi que cet homme est tombé
[Musique]
là
les embouteillages sont causées par le
carnaval les problèmes de navigation ne
cesse pas tout les gondoles stationnent
les unes à côté des autres
elles sont en file pour passer sur le
canal c'est vraiment très très gros
problème pour nous
[Musique]
pendant plusieurs décennies on a négligé
l'entretien des canaux et les niveaux
des marées sont six fois supérieure
depuis le début du siècle ce qui
fragilise les fondations de la ville on
est presque arrivé et ça tout est
complètement pourri
c'est pas
avec
des vagues provoquées par les bateaux on
releva des maisons sauf urgence
les pompiers ne peuvent pas dépasser les
4 kilomètres heure
à
[Applaudissements]
mais bon
ma cuisine italienne est vraiment bonne
alimentation c'est important pour les
pompiers pour être toujours prêt en
forme très dispo
même moi je ne peux pas expliquer la
fraternité qui existent entre nous c'est
une chose que l'on ressent
là on est tous ensemble on parle de
football le sport qu'on plaisante on se
charrie on se contredit et puis quand
l'alarmé sonne tout s'arrête
dimanche je me déguise en mousquetaire
je vois une moustache et une barbe le
carnaval est une fête païenne
on met des masques on se déguise pour
rompre la morosité change et d'une
atmosphère austère de notre vie
quotidienne et monotone le carnaval créé
plus de problèmes car il ya davantage de
monde quand il ya plus de personnes il y
a plus de confusion a plus d'incident
les gens qui ont des malaises plus
d'ambulance qui partent ici c'est pas
comme elle a fini il faut toujours
qu'ils viennent nous ennuyer allez
plutôt chercher les délinquants vous en
avez peur mais pas de nous le pire c'est
que l'on n'a rien fait mais les
délinquants vous avez trop peur ouais
ouais c'est ça bien sûr à la raison
c'est vrai
envahi par plus de huit millions de
touristes venus suffoque les étrangers
en tombe amoureux les vénitiens en
subissent le charme empoisonné les jours
de carnaval
il se réfugie dans le magnifique palais
et font la fête comme au xviie siècle à
l'époque le carnaval durer six mois
[Musique]
mais depuis les incendies du théâtre de
la fenice la peur du feu est devenu une
phobie
on en parle encore dans les salons
mon nouveau
[Musique]
avenue ce n'est pas comme dans les
autres villes vous pouvez sortir trouver
un taxi un téléphone dans ce panier il
n'y a même pas le téléphone vous savez
ici il faut une organisation
particulière s'il se passe quelque chose
ici et que personne notre téléphone
portable tout va brûler
[Musique]
là les appels venise et 10 lors qu'on
est en contact avec le standard
rester en contact
rester en contact si si regardez bien il
ya des balises des lumières il ya des
gros poteaux allô allô allô
dis moi quel endroit exact où vous vous
trouvez où elle chauffeur
[Musique]
la capote
a trop négligé les eaux de la lagune
venise pourrait bien période par les
flots beaucoup de bateaux se perdre dans
le brouillard comme celui-ci enlisé dans
les sables
[Musique]
une fois les touristes débarqués les
pompiers mettront plusieurs heures à
sortir le bateau de la vase
voilà tout
donnez moi madame donnez moi la main ben
c'est pas trop tôt
allez on avance
[Musique]
accompagné sur la terre ferme ces
touristes en sont quittes pour une belle
peur pour quelqu'un qui est né ici qui a
l'habitude de se promener avec sa
famille en bateau c'est facile il
connaît la lagune mais pour les pompiers
qui viennent d'ailleurs c'est plus
difficile de travailler à venise car ce
n'est pas comme sur la terre ferme
on ne peut pas donner de vrais direction
des repères comme premier à gauche
deuxième à droite céder le passage
[Musique]
dis donc elle style comment ça va
aujourd'hui alors qu'ils sont et autres
invités j'ai été pompier toute ma vie et
je le resterai jusqu'à la retraite
parce que j'ai trouvé une seconde
famille ici à part ma propre famille et
mes enfants
les pompiers sont la deuxième chose la
plus importante dans ma vie
le carnaval est une tradition à laquelle
nous tenons beaucoup et que nous voulons
perpétuer
nous commençons à habituer nos enfants
les temps sont durs et le carnaval le
rappeur des instants de bonheur
ils en prennent l'habitude et ainsi ils
ne laisseront pas mourir cette tradition
[Musique]
ça va
gardiens du passé et responsables
présents les pompiers de venise répondu
une fois de plus aux appels des
vénitiens